[APPLAUSE]
IKY SANDORFFY: My name is Iky.
I look after Google Play
business development
for Middle East and Africa.
And with me today
is Hugo, who's going
to come up on stage
in a couple of minutes
to talk about Maliyo Games, a
very successful game developer
out of Lagos, Nigeria,
who develops specifically
titles for emerging markets
out of emerging markets.
So today, you're going to hear
a lot of designated content
that speaks to growth
in user acquisition
and into device penetration.
But with this talk,
we'd like to invite
you to think about
the next billion users
and where they're going
to come from, particularly
with regards to user growth.
So we've seen
astounding development
in the last couple of years.
I'm sure we all have highly
capable devices in our pockets.
We have high-speed data
connection that are always on.
And the data you pay
for today is pretty much
a lot cheaper than it was just
two, three, or four years ago.
But every now and again,
it's important to really take
a moment and reflect
what has happened
over the last couple of years
that got us to this point,
and see how we can
take those learnings
to really continue and
accelerate that growth
over the next coming years.
Again, particularly with
regards to user growth.
So again, today
we will be talking
about building high-quality
games and apps that
work effectively, not
only for the user of today
but for the users of
the next coming years.
So we've seen tremendous
growth from emerging markets.
And we've projected about
80% of smartphone growth
globally is going to come
from emerging markets in 2019.
As more users get
access to these devices,
they get connected
for the first time.
And the first time making
any experiences with the web,
they will be
looking for new ways
to experience the internet, to
shop, to entertain themselves,
to communicate.
And that, in itself, is bringing
up a massive opportunity
for all of us in this room.
So again, 80% of smartphone
growth up until 2019
will be coming from
emerging markets.
So what's important
here is to then
look at the challenges
these users face,
and to start designing
experiences that
will cater to these challenges.
I'm backing this up with
numbers from Google Play
that Mark referenced in
his early keynote today.
We see a tremendous increase in
accelerated growth in downloads
as well as in consumer
spend from emerging markets.
And we don't see any
indication that this
is going to stop anytime soon.
So if you compare emerging
markets with developed markets,
we see significantly
faster growth,
just about four times as fast.
Well, consumer spend is double.
And we expect this
to further grow.
It's an exciting trend, and
it's important to realize
that this is happening.
Yet, put this in context and see
where this growth is actually
coming from.
So first, we all know
fast networks are awesome.
We all have instant information
and instant capabilities
in our pockets today.
But if you look at the reality
of today, still just about half
of mobile internet usage is
coming from a 2G connection.
And I'm setting out an
open question to this room,
when was the last time you
were on a 2G connection?
When was the last time you
actually opened your own game
or app from a 2G connection?
If you extrapolate this
out and project what's
going to happen until 2020,
we still expect 1 in 3 users
to be-- or just about 1
in 3 users to be on 2G.
And that resembles
about 1 billion users.
So definitely, a
massive opportunity.
But again, with
different challenges
that need to be
addressed accordingly.
For example, if you look at
the variation of network speed
and the availability of
networks just across the board,
you can see, for example here,
India on the center right.
Average speed of Indian
usage, Indian internet usage--
pardon me-- is about a
tenth of that in the UK.
While the quality and the
adoption of high-speed networks
is very low.
Just about 1 in 5, or 20%
of broadband connections
are above 4
megabytes per second.
So again, data availability
being very scarce
and the speeds once you
get there are very low.
So these users
behave significantly
different from the users today.
Finally, another one of key
challenges in emerging markets
is the data cost.
Data is expensive in
a lot of these markets
and they're just about
to go down in prices.
Just look at
comparative data here
that actually looks at
the comparative data cost
as relative to the gross
income of the median household
and you can see that at
a data plan in Nigeria
it's about 10 times as
much relative to the UK
so again these are super
sensitive to how data is
being consumed from your app.
And being good stewards
of their data plan
is just appreciated
and good business.
So with that in mind, we
want to help and drive
the engagement in those regions.
And to support the
growth in these markets,
we have created a framework,
which we call the next billion.
And it's centered around
six key topics which
I will outline very briefly now,
and reference some resources
where you can read up
in a lot more detail
about these elements.
So without further
ado, if you're
looking at the six
pillars that we
invite you to take
a look at, it's
connectivity, device,
compatibility, data cost,
battery consumption,
content, and commerce.
And again, I'm going to cover
everything very briefly.
We're going to be
here all afternoon
if you want to speak about
any of those in more detail.
So connectivity.
By the way, just
wanted to outline.
This by no means just the best
practice for emerging markets.
These are good practices
and good principles
to implement even
for the users today.
So connectivity.
You want to assure smooth
loading of your content.
You should prioritize
your bandwidth requests
and make sure that the top
requests are served first.
That the most useful
and relevant information
is loaded at the beginning.
For example, loading text
before you're loading images.
Don't duplicate your
network requests,
and save files locally
where applicable.
You could use the Connectivity
Manager, which is actually
a dynamic API that
gives you feedback
on what kind of connectivity you
should expect from this device,
and then change your
app serving accordingly.
Images are typically the biggest
perpetrators of slow load
time and slow connectivity.
So I invite you to think about
the standards of the images you
load.
Which formats which
resolution you actually load,
and where it becomes relevant.
And make sure that you're
using the appropriate sizes
of those images.
Lastly, with regards
to connectivity,
I encourage you all to look at
how your app and game performs
in an offline environment.
Just go ahead, turn your
phone into airplane mode.
Open up your app and
see what happens.
See where it
actually finds bugs.
See where it actually
gets stuck and what
experiences you need to improve
to assure a good offline
experience.
Moving on to device
compatibility.
A huge range of devices with
big screens, small screens,
expandable storage, small
storage, high-density screens,
and so forth.
I guess all of us face
the issue of developing
an app and a game
that can really
run on all of these devices.
So you should look at what
capacity your app is actually
invoking, and then
optimize for that.
Keep in mind that a lot of
these devices that we're
talking about are still 1
megabyte in RAM and below.
So you should think about
how your app actually runs
in these kind of environments.
And games should be
optimized to render smoothly
in those kinds of environments.
Look at screen sizes.
As I mentioned, these
devices that are coming on
are likely to be low cost.
They are likely to be
longer in their lifecycles.
And you want to make sure that
you have your exposure tested
on different screen
sizes, screen resolution,
and pixel densities.
[INAUDIBLE] mentioned
before that the new emulator
in Android Studio
is vastly improved.
It's increased in speed and it
allows you to test very quickly
for these elements.
So changing the device
resolution and the device size.
Just as an example, why would
you load high-resolution image
on a low-resolution device?
That's just a lot of waste
in many different factors.
Moving on to efficient
memory usage.
Users see that
screen at all time.
They can get a push
notification when
their memory is running out.
And they can actually
see a sorted list
of how much memory and
how much storage your apps
are actually using.
So here's the pro
tip for this one.
You can use the API
call of is low RAM
and actually get
feedback in real time
to figure out if this is
a highly-capable device
or a low-capable device.
And then, change your
processes accordingly.
Also, background processing.
Background processing
is typically
what drives up a lot of the
storage on the user's device.
And that's perfectly fine.
Many apps may invoke
processes in the background,
but you should be good stewards
of your user's device memory.
And so you want to start up
your background processes,
finish them, try to bundle
them into one round,
and then shut down the
process in order not
to drain the user's memory
as well as the battery.
Moving on to smart storage.
Think about installing or just
running this one line of code
that allows users to push
their apps onto their SD card.
This can go a long
way for devices
with expandable storage.
As I mentioned before,
users can actually
sort how much data is
consumed and how much space
is consumed on
your phone and can
see the list of the most
draining apps on top, which
will then drive a lot of the
uninstalls, uninstall rates up.
So you want to keep your device
consumption low and make sure
that you are frequently clearing
the cache that you're creating.
This one is a tip that
I'm sure you're not
going to hear often today.
So this is the
one and only time,
I guess, you will hear us today.
But think about
backwards compatibility.
Think about these
new users coming
online with slightly
older devices
and not necessarily always on
the latest version of Android.
So I'd invite you to run your
apps with the minimum SDK 14,
but target SDK 23 in
order to really cater
to a wide variety of users that
are being kept with the latest
features.
Also, think about integrating
the Google Play Services
API because it will ensure that
the users get updates on time.
And we will make sure that
the users are catered to
with the features that actually
work for their devices.
Moving on, and I'm
already finishing off.
So Hugo, get ready.
It's your time to
speak in a minute.
I'm looking at data costs.
As we said before, data is
expensive in these countries.
And it's only very
slowly becoming cheaper.
We're used to having
cheap, always-on data.
But the reality is
about half of users
don't have that privilege today.
Installing your app is an
actual cost to the user.
And think about how sizable
your APK actually is.
How much space and
how much data usage
the user's actually
going to consume
by just downloading your app.
If you have a prepaid package
for 200 megabytes a month,
how likely are you to
actually download a game that
is 100 megabytes on free data?
So again, think
about your APK size.
And there is a great talk from
Google I/O, which I encourage
you to take a look at.
It's called "Put
Your APK on a Diet."
Definitely, worth checking out.
The sweet spot for emerging
markets is around 10 megabytes.
That's what you
should be aiming for.
We see a high drop-off
with every megabyte
that you add in weight.
Now, we realize for a lot of the
game developers in this room,
this number is
completely unreasonable.
Building a high-quality 3D game
in 10 megabytes is very tricky.
And oftentimes, the
third-party libraries
you're using on
their own are already
exceeding those 10 megabytes.
So if you can't make
this number work,
and this number sounds
completely unreasonable to you,
consider multi-APK.
Launching multiple APKs into
different device categories
just to make sure that you can
cater to those users as well.
So again, users are
sensitive to APK sizes.
Images, as we noted before,
are the biggest offenders
with this.
You want to reduce
costs, and you
want to consider
multi-APK to serve this.
Again, Android Studio
and Firebase Analytics
allows you to test and
see how much data your app
is actually consuming.
You can benchmark the data.
And being, again, good
stewards of this data
will go a long way
with the users.
Moving to battery consumption.
You want to eliminate
unnecessary wake-ups.
You want to batch your network
requests whenever they come in.
And you want to use the
Network Manager API.
Again, which can give
you feedback on what
kind of network is expected.
Moving on to content.
Users everywhere want
tailored content.
We know this from our own data.
When we're looking
at Google Play
and we optimize it for
different scenarios,
highlighting and surfacing
specific tailored content
for a local audience, we
see significant improvements
in adoption and engagement.
So localization is important.
Think about fast,
responsive of UIs.
Think about the UI best
practices, which we talked
about today in material design.
These are all best
practices to really cater
to a user in a
local environment.
To make sure that
they feel at home
and that they feel that
this environment is
tailored for their use.
Last but not least, commerce.
We all strive to make this a
business and not just a fun
exercise.
So catering to those markets.
You want to adjust your
monetization strategy
accordingly.
There's multiple different
ways of driving revenue
from these markets.
Obviously, users are
more sensitive to price.
But you want to use multiple
different monetization schemes
to really figure
out what works best.
Some of which might
be best catered
to with in-app purchases while
other markets are specifically
more susceptible to ad revenue.
So when driving
different ways, we
want to make Google Play a
commerce platform for you
and enable good businesses
in those regions as well.
So think about the
barrier of entry.
Where do you want to charge?
At what levels and
what price points do
you want to charge
for your content?
And offer prices
in local currency.
We've just referred to earlier
about pricing templates.
I encourage you to use those.
And to make sure
that your prices
are adjusted in the local
currency at the right numbers.
And in addition to that,
you should also take a look
at the Big Mac
index, the purchasing
power of a single dollar
in a single country.
If you multiplied
that with the prices
you're actually charging,
you automatically
become more sensible
to that local market
because you're
charging something
that is actually equivalent
to what users can afford.
So I'm summarizing the
points we've made earlier.
And again, there's
a lot of resources
which I'll share
after Hugo's talk
on how to really look
at these best practices,
figure out which ones
are relevant for you,
and then go out
and implement them.
But if there's three main
pieces of information
that I would like to share today
and to encourage you to take
home with you after
this talk, it's
that 1 billion users will
still be on 2G by 2020.
The average mobile data speed
in Vietnam, India, Argentina,
Brazil is below 4
megabytes per second.
And the relative cost of
data in emerging market
is about 10 times higher
compared to that in the UK.
So think about fast apps that
are reliable and lightweight
in order to best cater for the
next billion users and leverage
that growth going forward.
With that, I would
like to-- oh, sorry,
that was the wrong button.
I would like to invite
Hugo Obi from Maliyo Games
to speak about his
experience developing
for emerging markets.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO OBI: Hi.
So it's a real pleasure
to be here today.
As Iky said, my
name is Hugo Obi.
I'm from Maliyo Games
in Lagos, Nigeria.
We build locally
relevant games, primarily
for the Nigeria market.
Our vision is to share
the African narrative
with the world through games.
Just show of hands, who has
been to the African continent
before?
Excellent.
And secondly, who's
been to Nigeria before?
Fantastic.
A few people in the room.
So you would understand how
unique this part of the world
is in terms of connectivity.
So I'll just run through a
little bit of a background
about Africa, talk a
little bit about Nigeria,
and then we're going to
go diving a little bit
into a specific
user segmentation
that I think would hopefully
enable you to understand
a little bit better
about the kinds of people
that you'll be targeting if you
decide to come into a market
like Nigeria.
So most of my time will be
spent talking about Nigeria.
Firstly, in terms of like
Africa as a continent,
some people still think
it's a single country.
But obviously, we have about
54 countries in the continent.
There's quite a lot
of languages there,
but the population
is very large.
But the connectivity in terms
of people who are actually
connected to the internet,
as you can see from here,
it's about 28.1% of
people who are connected.
This is a mobile
first market, which
means that a lot of people
who connect to the internet
actually experience
that connection
via their mobile devices.
So tablets, computers
are not as prevalent
as mobile devices are.
So in terms of
Nigeria-- and Nigeria
is a very, very large market.
We're just under 200 million
people in terms of population.
And we're the second largest
economy in the continent.
But what is really,
really interesting
is that we have a lot of
mobile connectivity, at least
compared to everybody else.
So we're just under
100 million people
who connect to the internet.
Mostly, via mobile devices.
In terms of people who actually
have access to mobile phones,
or the number of like
mobile lines that we have in
the country is
about 200 million.
So a lot of people have dual
devices, dual SIM cards.
And people are connecting
using multiple devices.
But what I'm really
excited about sharing today
is the user segmentation,
which I touched on earlier.
We've been able to
identify four unique custom
segments in Nigeria.
And these custom
segments are actually
defined by their connectivity.
So how they actually
connect to the internet more
than anything else.
But looking at Nigeria
as a broad market.
What is really interesting
from a social angle
is-- I don't know if you guys
are familiar with Nollywood?
It's the third
largest movie industry
in the world behind Hollywood
and Bollywood, of course,
from India.
It's actually the second
largest contributor to our GDP
after oil and gas.
So huge employer of people.
And the locals are
really, really keen
on their local movies.
Our music is actually
very huge exports.
So there's a lot of
hip hop music coming up
from Nigeria, which is
going across different parts
of the continent in
Africa and overseas.
Huge exports here
in the West as well.
So when you go to clubs and
bars in most popular cities,
you are more likely to come
across one of our musics.
Football is huge.
It's second to
religion in Nigeria.
We are fanatics when
it comes to football.
We love our premiership.
We love our LaLiga.
And you know, there was this
story about these two Nigerians
who got into a massive
fight over which footballer
was the best football
in the world, Lionel
Messi or Cristiano Ronaldo.
So we don't take
it very lightly.
Religion, like I
said, is-- pretty
much every street in
Nigeria has a church.
So I watched a
little clip recently
that showed that the top 10
richest pastors, depending
on what denomination you
are, but the top 10 richest
pastors in the world, 5
of them are Nigerians.
Four of whom are
actually in Nigeria.
So despite the fact that we do
have huge economic challenges,
people are very generous
when it comes to church.
And then, fashion is sort of
like becoming a modern trend.
And there's huge adoption
for fashion design.
People are very interested in
what they wear and are shopping
for these kind of things.
Politically, the way
the opportunities--
I mean, this is kind of like
opportunities and challenges
at the same time.
But politically,
what the government
is really interested
in is in education.
So education is a huge
challenge for the continent.
So any sort of apps
that enable people
to learn on the go on
their mobile device
is actually a very huge hit.
And then, anything
around empowerment
is also a very huge hit
because the government has
a very large youth population.
And getting these
people educated
and giving them
access to employment,
opportunities is actually
a huge challenge for them.
On the mobile side, Nigeria has
huge infrastructure problems.
So I actually came to
London via Cape Town.
And in Cape Town,
they have-- in South,
Africa they occasionally
have something
called load shedding,
which is where
people-- for a couple of hours
in the day, the government
is distributing power
between different districts.
It is possible for you
to actually lose power
for a couple of hours in a day.
In Nigeria, it's a
completely different thing.
I mean, there's no such
thing as load shedding.
It's just power outage.
And this is probably about
80%, 90% of the time.
For those of you
who've been to Nigeria,
it's a huge, huge, huge problem.
Which means that battery
life is actually hugely
important to mobile users.
Most people have
battery power packs
that they use with
their mobile phones,
but that is not sufficient.
Internet, like Iky said
earlier, is extremely expensive.
And that is
something that people
are very conscious about.
There's not a lot
of transparency
between the internet
service providers
and the actual end
consumers in terms of what
their data is being used for.
So you can buy a data
bundle of maybe 2 gigs
and it can run out
in a couple of hours.
And people don't have
a huge understanding
as to how their data
is actually being
utilized for the amount
of money they're paying.
Free peer-to-peer
communication tools
are massive because of
voice and data costs.
So people adopt these
products to enable
them to keep in touch
with friends and family.
And then, internet connectivity
is another huge challenge.
And this is around the
infrastructure difficulties
for a lot of the telcos and
internet service providers
in the country.
I'm going to dive into the
different user segments.
So earlier, I touched on
the four user segments.
So if you're bringing
a product into Nigeria,
looking at the
Nigerian market, these
are four unique
categories of users
based on their connectivity.
So we have what we termed
as the always-on segment.
Now, these guys are pretty
much the types of people
that you would expect to
meet in any developed market.
They're well-educated.
Most of them actually have some
level of foreign education.
They're well-traveled.
They earn a decent salary
by Nigeria standards.
They connect to the internet
via multiple devices.
What they really care about
is the connection speed more
than price.
They're not as price-sensitive.
They access their content
via the app stores.
They have multiple payment
options, so they can update.
They're very comfortable paying
with credit cards and debit
cards or using payment
platforms like PayPal
because they've lived abroad
and they understand the security
benefits or the convenience
benefits of actually doing
transactions online.
You would find them using
apps like Uber, YouTube.
They're huge video consumers.
And they play games
that require you to be
connected when you're playing.
So they're not too
bothered about that.
So that's the very first
group and represent about 5%
of the market.
The second group is what we
tag as the mostly on group.
So data cost is,
obviously, very expensive.
And these are sort of
the kinds of people
who swap between being
online and offline.
And this is kind of like trying
to manage the data that they
have access to or
they can afford.
They usually connect using
either a phone or a tablet.
We don't have a lot of fixed
landlines or cable connections,
so most people are connecting
using some kind of MyFi device
or some kind of router on,
obviously, the 3G connections.
Again, these guys are
reasonably educated.
They are employed,
semi-employed individuals.
They typically
purchase data bundles,
so there is some kind of
cap around what they buy.
So they would do like a 4
gig plan, or a 5 gig plan,
or a 10 gig plan
valid for 30 days.
So obviously, they are very
conscious of what they are
using their data to consume.
So they typically
use apps that enable
them some of offline access
as well as online access.
They're huge users of
communication tools
and have access
to games as well.
They access their games directly
from the app stores as well.
Because of their
level of education,
they understand how to use
stores like Google Play.
The next group is
our on-demand group.
So this group is
kind of like where
you start to see a lot more
people who spend more time
offline than they do online.
They usually access the
internet using product bundles.
So what product bundles
do is that there
is a basket of applications that
you can get unlimited access to
over a 30-day period.
So that would be like
your communication tools,
your social tools,
your instant messaging
tools, your emailing tools.
And this is what they
would typically pay for.
So their access to the
internet is actually
limited in that they
might not necessarily
be able to use a browser or
access YouTube in the same way
that they could actually use
Facebook, Twitter or Instagram.
Folks like this typically
have one device.
So they usually access
connections via their phone.
This is now where you start
to see a lot more people who
are using very low-end phones
or fairly-- secondhand phones,
actually, are also very
popular for this group.
In terms of
payments, they're not
very comfortable using cards
or using any payment platforms.
So they would do direct
carrier billing for payment.
They're more comfortable
paying with cash.
And in terms of how they
access content for their mobile
devices, they
would typically use
file sharing share
and applications
to access pretty much
access applications offline.
I don't know if you guys
are familiar with Xender,
but Xender is a very popular
application for this group.
And then the last group
that we're going to look at
is where majority
of the population
actually falls into
from our analysis.
Somewhere around about
75% of the population
falls into this group.
So this is like your
self-employed, your artisans.
They're mostly uneducated.
Again, they would
access the internet
if you had product bundles
or limited price plans.
But most of the time
they're actually offline.
They're now using like really,
really low-end feature phones.
A lot of Chinese
manufacturers are
entering into the market
with really basic devices
for this segment.
In terms of how they
access the apps, when
they go to the markets
to purchase the phones,
there are people in the markets
that actually install the app.
So they pay to actually
have apps installed.
So this group is
more likely not to be
familiar with app stores
and the sort of freedom
that they can actually
have with accessing the app
stores on their own.
In terms of their
top apps, you're
more likely to see
them using browsers,
like Opera, which allows them
to actually get faster speed.
Get access to the internet
without necessarily utilizing
like a huge level of bandwidth.
So the last thing
I want to touch on
is this matrix of like
how all of these things
are connected to the design
principles for the next billion
users.
So in terms of
connectivity, there's
a lot of awareness
around the fact
that most of the
people who are going
to be accessing the
internet will be
using like 2G/3G connections.
A lot of people are going to
be using low-end smartphones
and feature phones
in some instances.
For internet connection or
[INAUDIBLE] connectivity,
it's going to be mostly
around like pay-as-you-go,
some kind of pay-as-you-go
limited product bundle package
which they'll be using.
So yeah.
I mean, that's just kind of
my thoughts on the subject.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]